hello welcome to the labyrinth webcast
on our team science project that we
entitle neuronal circuit mechanisms of
memory require this nih brain initiative
team science project is led by four of
us do reboot Jackie from NYU
Attila law Shanti from Columbia
University March Nitzer from Stanford
and myself even salt is also from
Stanford and I should add that this
project was initially up to a large
extent conceived in close collaboration
with the late John lisman whose ideas
still guide us today the general goal of
this project is written here on the
slide and I'm going to unwrap it for you
so the general goal is to make the first
attempt to fully understand a
cognitively important event called
memory replay during hippocampal
shortwave ripples in terms of the
detailed properties of the brain cells
and circuits involved so let's discuss
this a little bit in more detail what
are hippocampal sharp waves why do we
think it's a cognitively important event
and what does it mean to fully
understand such an event so short played
ripples which we abbreviate as SP wr's
in this presentation our local field
potential oscillations at high
frequencies 100 to 200 Hertz you see it
on the number 1 on the left this these
events can be recorded with an electrode
placed a large relatively large
electrode that we refer to as a local
field potential electrodes placed into
the hippocampal pyramidal cell layer in
the ca1 and occasionally when a animal
is at rest
you see these hydric
oscillations the short wave ripples the
short wave ripples or ripples are often
co-occurring the fastest elations often
co-occurring with a slower way wave that
we call short wave and this complex
together is what we refer to as sharp
babe reports they are generated at a
very high level just as a first
approximation they are generated by fast
gaba ojik inhibitory interneuron and
pyramidal cell interactions where the
pyramidal cell gets excited by input
from the ca3 the presynaptic ca3 region
through Schaffer collaterals the excited
sieve on pyramidal cells then drive
local inter neurons and the local
inhibitory interneurons and inhibit back
on the pyramidal cells of the c1 and
this cycle if you want resonates at high
frequencies at hundred Hertz or or above
these are the ripples now why are these
ripples are important for memory we know
from several groups and there is furious
groups results are shown on the right we
know that they are important for memory
because if we selectively suppress these
these events the spatial memory is
performance is decreased so that's why
we know that these events are not just
there in the brain they actually serve
an important function and importantly
also these events are not just there in
the rodents such as mice and rats but
they are actually present in all mammals
that people have looked at now what does
it mean to understand an event like this
we borrowed or we are guided by a set of
criteria that people who work on simple
nervous systems in the crab and other
organism lobsters developed a set of
criteria that they saw to be much
meet to understand in your north circuit
and its function and you see the list
there so first of all you have to
identify the cell types in the circuit
you have to describe their connectivity
and the distribution of the connection
strength we have to determine the
intrinsic conductance is of neurons each
neuronal cell we have to measure the
overall output of the system and then we
have to determine how this output is
affected by inactivation of individual
cell types and we can create a
computational model incorporating the
properties of the cells they involved
and their connections and the critical
test of understanding is whether the
model can replicate or reproduce the
experimentally measured output of the
network in order to arrive at this
understanding we use a set of advanced
advanced experimental and computational
modeling techniques some of which are
shown here and you will hear about them
in more detail so for example otavalo
shanties lab is using simultaneous two
photon imaging and electrophysiology in
behaving animals in the multi-sensory
context Oh Julie pooja Keyes lab uses
for example various of the silicon
probes for large-scale electrophysiology
oh recordings and optogenetic
manipulations in freely moving animals
mark schnitzels lab uses ensembl calcium
and voltage imaging in behaving mice and
uses various techniques that allow in
vivo optical imaging across the entire
dorsal surface of the cortex of the
mouse and my lab uses multi scale
computational modeling techniques to
model and really understand hippocampal
networks so what are the big questions
that we are trying to get it at this in
this project one of them is how are
Sharpie ripples initiated what are the
external and internal controllers what
are the external
what are the controllers that are
external to the hippocampus
for example the internal cortex or the
or some other brain structure that may
be connected to it and what are the
internal controllers for example the
circuitry of the ca3 or the dentate
gyrus how do they play a role in
initiation now the big question is the
sequencing that occurs during sharp
Avery polls and you will hear about this
in the second presentation and how our
shock wave ripples terminated what are
the cellular synaptic mechanisms of
sequencing and termination how are
memories stored and replayed during
sharp Avery polls how is the content of
sharp egg ripples routed through
distinct output paths pathways and
finally we use theory and modeling of
hippocampal networks during sharp during
spatial navigation and memory replay to
really understand how all of this
happens in terms of the cells and
synapses involved I should say that the
experiments are guided by theory and
modeling and the theory and modeling in
turn is informed by the experiment so
this is really an interactive project
between experiments and theory modeling
now this brain steam science project is
really a team science project in the
sense that the various groups located at
three universities are really
interacting to come up with joint
projects and there's a lot of extensive
and extensive added value if you want of
this team science project it's really
more than the sum of its parts not just
in terms of the joint projects that we
do the collaborations that occur but
also there is extensive technology
transfer between the labs there's free
exchange of ideas and early feedback on
projects which are really important we
can discuss these and we do discuss the
the early
results with each other throughout the
labs and it's really helpful to guide
how the research is going or
postdoctoral and graduate student
trainees visit each other labs and they
form important links with other postdocs
and graduate students and interact with
the PI's all of this of course presents
a lot of new networking possibilities
and new collaborations that can actually
take place even outside of this brain
team science project with with other
labs in the in the States and outside we
also think that the data sharing that
occurs between the labs is an excellent
if you want laboratory for testing new
data formats that allow the extensive
sharing of data and computational
modeling results across the labs as well
as with outside labs so without further
ado let me now hand over the
presentation to do rebou jockey for NYU
Thank You hippocampal shop a rickles
have the reputation of being the most
synchronous pattern in the mammalian
brain as you can see in this figure the
LFE pattern in recorded from the ca1
region of the hippocampus very nicely
classifiers various behaviors into two
major classes we can call them theta or
explore in the activity or still
activity its associated with the sharp a
ripples that corresponds to the larger
category of kazuma three behaviors it is
visible from the figure that this
patterns are strikingly different when a
shop name occurs that corresponds to the
depolarization of the apical dendrites
of Savon pyramidal cells and because of
the stronger excitation coming into the
decision the the tunnel between finding
interneurons and pyramid
sells produces a various fast about 150
Hertz ripple oscillation so you can see
on the figure here that this is the
Shelf a the dendrites and here in the
same I'm pyramidal layer
we've got people's now ripples have a
reputation not because not only because
they are very strongly synchronized but
also because of the spike content in
this next figure I'm showing you 13
pyramidal cells which are also placed
cells which means that when anybody is
going from left to right on this track a
sequential activity of these euros will
be correlated with the animals position
these are called place cells now the
remarkable thing about this this
activity is that at the beginning of the
journey the same exact cells are also
firing and and you can see it from here
they are firing exactly in the same
order but much faster in a much
compressed way then during the journey
itself even more remarkably at the end
of the journey when the animal is again
rewarded here at this end and is
involved consumer tree behavior then the
replay is reversed in the reverse
direction now this phenomenon has been
named in barriers by various terms such
as memory consolidation planning
imagination internalized deliberation
and others and it has been investigated
it many many laughs in various species
including humans now over the past
several years many new questions aroused
and I'd like to summarize the three
manager areas where I think we have to
focus a little bit more the first one is
the specificity of the shop fabric or
the specificity by specificity I mean is
that there is a a extraordinary or they
on the one hand on the spectrum beam
assume that there is a very strong
relationship between what one can see is
the waking behavior such as shown here
and the replay time that occurs during
sleep or
kazuma three behaviors and in a
compressed manner so here the colors are
exactly
mushiya it's a very precise replay on
the other end of the spectrum we can say
mmm there is absolutely no relationship
between what happens if they wake him
say and what happens in the DVD - our
favorite was the truth is probably
somewhere in between and in various
circumstances and various conditions we
see something in between these two
extremes so this is a task for the
future to figure out under what
conditions experience may change this is
a tractor state and choose which one is
activated and for what reason
the second issue that I'd like to
introduce is that the modifications and
the replay happens not only in the
hippocampus because this replay currents
are very powerful and they are affecting
very large parts of the the rest of the
brain including the neocortex and then
the question is whether the video codecs
also has a similar replay so what is
shown in the the left side left side
here is the replay in the hippocampus
during a phase we can call its primary
reading and then the downstream reader
structures such as the neocortex can can
do the secondary reading and of course
it's not very clear whether they but
what is the how faithful it is from this
pattern to this pattern and the same
problem can be also posed to the
neocortex as I just explained a slide
ago in the campus now the further
complication of course is that the
neocortex and the other readers are
quite complicated and they have their
own lives and productivity so they can
read out various patterns in other words
the same exact shar-pei ripple can mean
totally different things in firdaus the
breathers and these are showing that the
cartoon here depending on what is it
depending on the transformation function
of the structure the interpretation of
the hip comparable could be quite
different in one area another here is a
extreme example there are two major ways
how you can read out the the hippocampal
pattern what is through
for example all the booze from the
hippocampus can converge upon the same
exact cell such as can happen in the
nucleus accumbens or it can happen in
lateralis have to oh the other way
around which is the other extreme is
that this this relatively compact
hippocampus can be read out or the
content of the focus can read out by
multiple multiple readers in a in a
fan-out version
so this reader and this video this
survey can interpret something totally
different than $1 trillion area so let
me show you an example of the femmine or
convulsions result this is an
illustration of the very strong
conventions from the see anyone in the
sea it's religion pyramid ourselves onto
the septum and you can see that they are
overlapping quite a lot and there is a
nice topographical relationship between
various hippocampal circular and
internal relations in the lateral septum
because of these strong comedians there
is also a ripple generate in the
Pellicano septum and many neurons are
firing at the time when the sharp a
ripple occurs in the campus and the
question here is that what is the the
interpretation of this down till
structure about the hippocampal output
and the answers is not complicated but
can be simplified in a way by saying
that there is not much information
available for the latter except
ourselves about this sequence or
activity it doesn't matter whether they
sequence is ABCD or the other way around
as it's shown by these analyses here
what the knuckle receptor cells really
worry about is the total amount of
excitation Tennessee from the lot from
the hippocampal out in this summarize
here a lot of a cell or cells don't see
and don't read the details of the
sequential activity of the hippocampus
but they integrate the overall activity
that is the arena is synchrony from camp
loud now let's see the other example dye
mergers
a good example of the divergence is when
we start from the ca1 region this they
actually can go the Civic alone from
semi-colon to the retro spinning our
cortex and then it turns out to be a
very large area of the neocortex
and so this is already a very strong
connection and people want to know what
is the relationship between the
hippocampus and a Dyson optic target
here such as mattress pad Liacouras we
have we can put in the electrodes in
both structures and what we can see is
that there is a nice relationship during
hippocampus shock waves between the
seeing one region with its own ripples
and in the superficial layers of the
retro spinning of codex in this little
cartoon down here you can see that many
neurons can respond during hippocampal
ripples in the retrofitting of cortex
the question is whether these patterns
are identical independent of the pattern
of the of the ca1 output or from whether
they see a one output
sends out with various patterns and then
there is a differential response in each
time that there is a different output
coming out from the hippocampus so this
is done quantitatively by clustering the
population vector that is how and which
order neurons fire in a given time
window and if we have about 100
hippocampal neurons we can make those
these clusters and in this particular
session we ended up with 10 clusters so
each of these clusters are shown here
and they the bottom line here is that
within clusters the activity patterns is
very similar and the crosstalk across
clusters they the activity patterns are
quite dissimilar and of course the
interesting problem here is that better
the downstream leaders can discriminate
between these artificial pluses or
clusters that we made artificially first
let's look at what happens in the
hippocampus and we are zooming in to
cluster 1 2 3 and a and you can see not
only the magnitude by the the neurons
that are involved these are the activity
patterns are proportional with the
yellow color you can see that in this
case there are there are differences
between these it's not only in the
hippocampus that classifies these Paris
that's what happens in the campus but
also the letter explaining Accord EX so
for example you need cluster 1 you can
see that initially there is quite a bit
of inhibition of codecs using plastic -
is an exciter a pattern mostly in the
bottom neurons and then it's different
in every single case so this is a
population readout these are about 200
neurons here that are simultaneously
reading out and discriminating pattern 1
2 3 4 and so on now the issue is whether
there are individual neurons that are
capable of doing that and the answer is
yes so I'm showing you one two three
four individual retrofitted neurons and
each of the ten patterns here and each
of the the ten petals also shown here
and on different number of trials and
again the summary picture here is that
there are neurons Indian in their
posterior cortex that are tuned to one
for example number seven cluster and
they respond exclusively and that number
seven that is one of the particular
patterns is recurring this particular
neuron likes to respond whenever number
7 and number nine categories are present
in the hippocampus and there are several
other examples as well so to summarize
this part different town steel
structures and neurons individual
neurons can read out with different
constellations of neuronal population
patterns of chakra ties now this was a
small structure just a retrospective
codex and of course they they the
neocortex is enormous so we would like
to introduce new methods that allow us
to read out what how the the entire
neocortex entropies hippocampal outputs
in order to do that we come by
electrophysiology and Y field imaging
methods and this way you can image the
entire right hemisphere or almost that
is those are part of the entire
hemisphere here he is a little result
showing there depending how the
neocortical parents called down and
upstairs
to the shockwave parents and their
interactions can produce various
interactions and they show that are
shown by the readout of this very
complicated traveling patterns of
activity now obviously this is a very
crude resolution panels so you know that
you improve that we would like to know
what aspects of the hippocampal outputs
are useful and important and the next
fighting I'm showing here is that that
depending on the duration of the shock
wave patterns the magnitude of the
neocortical is false showing by these
red arrows there is quite a bit in order
to zoom into the signal cells of course
it would be good to have very large
scale high resolution technics and this
is where we collaborate with the
schnitzels group because we have to rely
on much better matters that the ones we
have at the moment so if the wider shop
face they have a stronger influence on
them we wondered are they better hose
when we were by the shop face does it
make any difference for the rest of the
brain and has for behavior and indeed
what we found and there is a difference
between the short and long sharp face
and the distribution of the shaft
durations show a several of magnitude
the distribution and and and can be
described by a lognormal pattern so this
is a logarithmic scale this is the
duration and what we find is that there
this right tail of the distribution is
important because whenever the animal is
in the normal environment there are more
longer shock waves
the same applies also when we compare
the shock wave durations in tasks where
there is a memory requirement or there
is no memory requirement when the memory
is required that animal has to memorize
something then during replace the sharp
edges are longer even in the same task
we can ask what happens then the animal
is performing correctly a trial or makes
an error and they are say is there on
correct
was the probability that the shop is a
longer is higher compared with the the
anima makes an error so if this is the
interesting observation that shinobi
shop is a better so to speak then we
wondered what happens if we artificially
prolong the duration of the shop a
purpose to do that we expressed general
of sins in c1 pyramidal cells and
whenever sháá-faced occurred in a
closed-loop manner we added an extra 100
millisecond you can see here that's the
prolongation of the ongoing shop
favorable to our surprise and happiness
we found that indeed when we
artificially of the genetically prolong
the the shock wave ripples and any
further content spiking contact to the
ripple then working memory performance
was improved that is a short summary
here namely the Euro sequences of longer
ratio equals cover a very large parts of
their house because the people duration
seems to replay a longer route that the
animal is planning ahead and this is
critical for memory and even the times
when we artificially use longer shoppers
then that route extension can be
achieved now the summer I thought I had
said that in this presentation we have
to address the issue of primary link of
shop every post meeting the structure
beneath the hippocampus and how these
secondary that is the downstream targets
are reading it and I explained there
Fenian readers such as the lateral
septum mostly was secretive as fellow
readers such as the neocortex can read
out with multiple aspects of the shop
editors and I haven't discussed much
about point number four but that's also
a very critical issue of course is how
experience can bias what kind of
attractor how many different types and
what are the dominant types and what are
the constellations of spiking activities
that played out after the animal
and ask and to summarize the last part
it seems that longer ripples are needed
for memory and even artificial
prolongation of her people can make
memory a little bit better now
this was the this the summary of our
project but of course it very
effectively dovetails into the
presentation of the the other members of
the u-19 the replay is is being
investigated by each of us and in the
next presentation until the Lotion see
in explain how calcium imaging can be
utilized to record even larger number of
neurons during shot variables and
understand their mysteries thank you so
my name is at evolution say and I like
to tell you about our recent research on
how we use large-scale functional
calcium imaging to study
neural mechanisms of long-term memory in
the hippocampus so a fundamental
function of the mammalian brain is to
learn and remember and our extended
human capacity to perform and maintain
long-term memories largely defines our
conscious experience so long-term
spatial and episodic memories are
critical for our daily life for example
we have to remember where we parked our
car adjusting a short-term but also in
the long term parking lot at the airport
but how do we form and maintain mental
maps of the world around us over long
timescales a mechanistic understanding
of these processes remains a
long-standing challenge and our team is
interested in understanding how the
neural circuitry in the mammalian and
more specifically in the road and people
campus as our model system supports
learning and the formation of long term
memories so what do we already know
about these processes let me highlight
just a few major findings the central
role of the hippocampus in long-term
spatial learning and episodic memory has
been long established by human
pathophysiological studies indicating
that damage to the hippocampus severely
impairs patients such as the famous
asians ability to learn and
remember new information about people
places and events that together
constitute or autobiographical memories
also a large body of experimental work
points to long-term changes in the
strength of synaptic connectivity
between neurons in the hippocampus as
candidate cellular and molecular
mechanisms of long-term spatial and
episodic memory third we also know about
a striking stellar activity correlate of
spatial navigation and learning that has
been identified across all processing
modes of the hippocampus and this is the
spatially restricted firing of
excitatory principal cells and
restricted locations as the individual
explores the environment these cells are
historically called playstyles and
together they tile the surrounding
environment and form a cognitive mental
map it is widely thought that specific
changes in this cognitive map can encode
an anchor station and episodic memories
finally as you also heard in the
previous book hippocampal memory has
multiple stages that are associated with
distinct network of sila Tory patterns
that can be captured with local field
potential recordings so memories are
initially formed an encoded during
exploration which we can call online
activity state of the hippocampus and
this is associated with with mcfife 10
Hertz
deep oscillations to form lasting
memories this initial encoding phase is
followed by selectively strengthening of
memories during a second offline memory
consolidation phase that occurs for
example during immobility or slow wave
sleep importantly this consolidation
phase is filtered over multiple days and
as you also heard in the previous
presentation during this offline state
LFP activity is mostly irregular but it
is occasionally interrupted with large
amplitude short duration population
bursts events or short wave people's and
a large body of research has
demonstrated that online playstyle
sequences are reactivated or replay
during the
short wave ripples and this repeated
time contrast reactivation of online
sequences are thought to be critically
important for long-term memory
consolidation in the previous talk you
heard from dr. Lu Jackie about how
ripples and fan-out memory related
information from the hippocampus that
can be read out by downstream cortical
and subcortical targets in a
complementary set of experiments we ask
the opposite question does ripple
related memory reactivation affect the
stability of neural representation
within the hippocampus and if so does it
affect all the cell's equally or it's
more important for some but not the
others a major obstacle to
experimentally investigating this
problem is that classic
electrophysiological recordings cannot
reliably track large populations of
neurons over multiple days during which
memory consolidation is thought to occur
luckily there is a complementary
approach functional custom imaging that
offers just this ability
so in our lab we'll be missing two
photon custom imaging to simultaneously
track the activity of large number of
cells in the mouse hippocampus this
approach allows us to detect changes in
intracellular calcium levels that is
evoked primarily by changes the neural a
neuronal spiking activity and to measure
their spatially localized playstyle like
activity at the single cell level as it
is shown on the lab however we can also
reliably track the same neurons over
multiple days which is critical for
monitoring memory consolidation and
finally we can monitor the activity of
several hundreds of places
simultaneously so hundreds CROSSMARK
opposed doctor a scientist in my lab who
previously used large-scale
electrophysiological recordings to study
ripples in the Buju cooler so to take
advantage of calcium imaging and combine
it with electrophysiology to study rural
mechanisms of long-term memory
consolidation and in particular to
answer the question whether a rapport
native memory replay affect the
stability of Hippo can
place the maps over long timescales
during learning for this undress
developed the method combining locally
potential recordings to detect ripples
and simultaneous two-photon calcium
imaging to track the activity of large
populations of hippocampal neurons in
the mouse in the learning task the mouse
has to navigate to find a reward
location on a wheelchair reality track
during which mr. sequences can be
recorded in addition unless recorded an
image of light the coastline activity
before and after these learning sessions
during which ripples are particularly
abundant importantly these recordings
were carried out over multiple days to
answer questions about the attack of
ripple related reactivation along with
inner stability of people come from maps
so on each day individual play styles
such as this hundred and sixty
simultaneously image cells about shown
here extubated spatial destructive deals
at discrete locations on the virtual
environment nicely filing the whole
navigational track
we then could compare the stationary
static fields of neurons longitudinally
over multiple days what you see here are
neurons that are aligned based on their
peak spatial response on day five and
leading it what we found that some you
are shown in red
stable code for location across days
while other neurons shown in blue either
change or lose their placed fields
implying the presence of both stable and
unstable coding elements in the
hippocampal longitudinal memory code so
this was an exciting result so next we
could move on to an answer our main
scientific question whether this
variability in the longitudinal
stability results from differential
recruitment of these cells to report and
to answer this we first looked at
offline a box before and after running
many animal was in mobile and shortly
because occur frequently so my calcium
imaging as you saw a powerful method to
monitor online crystal activity we still
didn't know if this method
also allow us to detect population
dynamics during the short duration
people events so the movie in the middle
shows the population calcium image
response or people can program it
ourselves to LSP detected ripples and
hopefully you can see what is actually
is summarized on the right panel that
LFP reports are associated with
transient widespread and large amplitude
calcium responses so these shortcuts in
responses confirm that our imaging
method has to require temporal
resolution to study the high timescale
of ripple related neuronal reactivation
what was even more exciting to us the
things in costume imaging were able to
observe that within these individual
population events priest has reactivated
in the same sequence as observed during
the previous running bout there are two
events showing forward replay of taster
sequences during the polls on the left
and reverse replay on the right similar
that you have seen in the previous
presentation using electrophysiological
recordings here you can see another
sixth example sequences from three-round
and post parts of the learning trial by
quantifying the amount of sequence mass
associated with ripples we found that
placed ESS sequences were enhanced
during and after more directed learning
behaviors as shown on the upper right
consistent with the learning dependency
of the PO related memory replay so one
take-home message is that cellular
resolution calcium imaging is a powerful
tool to study memory replay now with
this method in hand we can correctly
examine the putative role of ripples in
memory consolidation and we did this by
testing whether we could use individual
placed as learning related changes
during the early phases of the learning
to predict the future place mood
instability as the bottles on the Left
summarizes indeed found that says that
were preferentially recruited to repose
or another were cells that we call
positive ripple gear cells were
associated with increased long-term
stability this means that we were able
to
directly observed for the first time the
role of ripples a multi-day memory
consolidation interestingly however we
also found that the stabilizing effect
of ripple recruitment was the largest
workplace cell coding far from the
reward the clot in the middle and the
right showed the stability of cross the
spatial coding as a function of position
in the virtual environment for cell that
had negative or positive ripple game
what we found was that the negative
ripple gain group in the middle panel
showed the specific decreasing cross
based ability farther from the reward
location in the middle of the track in
contrast says that were recruited to
ripples were stable both near and port
from the reward as it shown on the right
panel of course what you may have
guessed already during this learning
past the animal likes to spend more time
at the reward location just like we
ideally spend more time in our favorite
restaurant when we go out and not
sitting in a traffic so therefore our
result is consistent with the model in
which hippocampal memory consolidation
actively compensates for rewards field
behavioral sampling of the environment
and promotes the stabilization of
station accurate and more useful long
turns facial mats
now you may also wonder if this result
actually makes sense
don't they actually want to
preferentially remember important events
and locations such as the reward in this
past maybe the next example can help to
contextualize our findings when we move
to a new city we initially form a map
that contain a list of most important
locations for example pizza joints a
subway station or the Central Park in
New York City but very little details
between these locations with experience
we form a finer grain high resolution
representation of the city that we can
also use the charting trajectories and
shortcuts between them and for this we
also need to represent the actual path
and trajectory between them so the major
take-home message of this talk is that
our results in dictate the hippocampal
repo
related memory replay actually hard to
form and consolidate long-term memories
that include both salient locations and
the paths between them in a mental map
finally I also hope to convinced you
that functional calcium imaging is a
powerful approach to answer questions
about memory replay and consolidation
and in the next presentation dr. mark
sheets are another member of our team
will tell you about how we can also
develop and use even larger scale
imaging methods across the whole
cortical mental and to directly image
voltage signals in the brain to study
memory thank you
you
I'm mark schnitzer
departments of biology and Applied
Physics at Stanford University as well
as the Howard Hughes Medical Institute
and today I'm going to tell you about
how my lab has been developing and
applying optical approaches for studying
how the brain stores and recalls
long-term memories together with my
collaborators as part of an NIH green
initiative u19 grant project now for
many studies of long-term memory we
would like to be able to combine
different methods that together will
allow us to track the activity of large
neural populations over extended time
periods pertinent to long-term memory
first we'd like to be able to image
neurons regardless of whether they might
fly in deep or in superficial brain
areas we would like to perform
time-lapse imaging experiments of these
neurons over days and weeks over the
course of a long-term memory experiment
we want to be able to watch the dynamics
of these cells in freely behaving
animals performing natural behaviors
together these approaches often produce
very large datasets on the order of tens
of terabytes or more and it's important
that we have computational analytic
approaches that are up to the job of
analyzing these large datasets and as I
will seek to illustrate today the
combination of all these different
methods has afforded us new
possibilities for studies in which we
can track the dynamics of large mineral
populations over extended time periods
in the context of a memory experiment
and I'm now going to introduce you to
these elements individually and show you
how we can apply so a number of years
ago we developed implantable optical
microscopes or optical micro needles
that can provide us micron scale
resolution of neurons residing deep
within the brain of live animals and
here you can see two different examples
of these optical microscopes the one on
the left is a thousand microns in
diameter this one is 350 microns in
diameter at the tip of each you can see
a little micro optical objective lens
they
gives us the microns resolution we need
to see individual cells and has followed
in each case by much longer but weaker
relay lens whose main purpose is to give
us the reach we need to penetrate into
deep brain tissue
now these endoscopes can be permanently
implanted into the live adult mouse
brain and to illustrate here I'm showing
you some time-lapse image datasets taken
from the ca1 area of the hippocampus in
the live adult mouse that is expressing
a fluorescent marker in ca1 hippocampal
pyramidal cells and you can see that
using these implants and microscopes we
can come back again and again over
periods of 2 months or more to these
individual neurons as shown here on the
left and as shown in this middle column
you can see that we have the precision
of return to come back again and again
to individual neuronal dendrites now for
our u19 project we are applying this
approach in collaborate collaboration
with Eva and soul sisters lab to be able
to image neurons repeatedly in the super
mammal area nurses this approach even
gives us the precision to track
individual synapses as illustrated here
again using fluorescently labeled
hippocampal pyramidal cells you can see
from these images in this time-lapse
data set that we can come back to
individual dendritic spines as indicated
with these arrowheads and these are
postsynaptic morphological structures
and the vast majority of excitatory
neurons that these ca1 pyramidal cells
received and you can see over this 3
week or so period has some of the
dendritic spines and hence synapses
persist over the course of the
experiment new spines arise midway
through other spines disappear and yet
another population is recurring
throughout the experiment and so you can
see we have very good precision of
return to individual neurons and
individual neural subcellular elements
another important tool for us in our
studies of memory is a miniature optical
microscope that has a mass of about 2
grams
based on semiconductor optoelectronics
and is small and light enough that it
can be mounted on the head of an adult
mouse as it naturally behaves my
colleagues and I at Stanford originally
developed this technology and we have
since commercialized it through a
company known as in scopic s-- they're
over 400 labs using this approach
worldwide and over a thousand
microscopes in the field and for
financial disclosure my colleagues and I
continue to have a financial interest in
in scope X this slide shows you a little
bit more about how the microscope works
and the parts that are inside the
microscope is used in conjunction with a
micro endoscope that is implanted into
the brain area of interest here in the
right you can see a magnified view of
the miniature microscope there's a micro
optical objective is the miniaturized
fluorescence dichroic and filter set
which resides here on the side is a
printed circuit board which carries LED
illumination and in the top is another
printed circuit board that carries a
cell phone cell phone CMOS camera for
the acquisition of images this
technology was originally the product of
three different PhD dissertations at
Stanford done in collaboration with my
Stanford colleague Abass al Kamal and it
was the five of us that originally
started in scopus as I mentioned earlier
this slide gives you an example of the
miniature microscope at work on the Left
we see an adult mouse wearing the
miniature microscope it has a micro
endoscope implanted in the ca1 region of
hippocampus and on the right you can see
neural calcium activity and the cell
bodies of c1 pyramidal cells expressing
a genetically encoded calcium for us an
indicator and so those fluorescing spots
are cell bodies that are firing first of
action potentials we can track the
neural activity concurrently with the
animal behavior we're seeing the
activity patterns of about 700 neurons
at once
this slide shows you that we have the
ability to identify the locations of
hippocampal neurons as well as their
corresponding time traces of activity
not shown here this is a very favorable
Mouse in fact it's our best one ever in
which we were able to extract over 1200
ca1 pyramidal cells from one Mouse in a
single imaging session and the cell
bodies are shown here in red overlaid a
green image showing the fluorescence
background from the brain tissue when we
record the activity patterns of
hippocampal neurons in this way we see
their their their their typical place
coding properties as it's been well
documented in the scientific literature
this is illustrated here using two
different enclosures or arenas a square
box and a circular box seen from a
bird's eye view and we look at the
locations of the mouse in the box and
how it relates to the activity patterns
of individual cells we find that the
individual neurons preferentially fire
when the mouse is in one location of the
box so let's take a look here and cell
348 when we place the mouse in the
square box this neuron preferentially
fires when the animals in the south but
if we pick up the mouse and move it to
this circular box you can see that cell
348 preferentially is active when the
animals in the Northeast and not every
cell is very active in all the boxes and
they can often have different locations
that are preferred as you can see here
for cell 348 so 159 is active generally
only one of these boxes it likes to fire
in the northwest and the square box but
not so much in the circular box and
vice-versa for cell 198 preference he
fires here in the southwest of the
circular box and not so much in the
square box and these kind of remapping
qualities are well established in the
literature but now we can see them
optically in freely behaving animals we
can have many microscopes working at
once as illustrated here in this montage
of brain videos acquired from five
different mice the microscopes in this
case have been implanted in the dorsals
for item and this slide illustrates that
even when the course of a single
afternoon of experimentation we can
acquire there
large data sets in the range of a
terabytes 10 tens of terabytes or more
so it's very important that we have the
computational pipeline that is up to the
job of analyzing all this data and over
the last several years my colleagues and
I have developed a substantial body of
code that allows us to do this this
pipeline is schematized here and I'm not
going to go through all the details but
we have different modules one which is
dedicated to inputting the video data
another dedicated to pre-processing the
video data this third module is perhaps
the most important this is where we
extract the identities of the individual
neurons and their corresponding time
traces of activity and here in this
fourth module we can register the cells
and their identities across the multiple
different days of a time-lapse imaging
experiment allowing us to track
faithfully individual neurons over
extended time periods I'm now going to
illustrate how we can use our
computational approaches to extract new
information about memory so here's a
case in which we trained a mouse to run
back and forth in a linear track an
environment that was very familiar to
the animal the black traces showed the
animals actual passage back and forth
through space by extracting the
activities of individual neurons and
using machine learning methods we can
deduce from the calcium video datasets
alone where the animal was in space and
so here you can see from the red traces
the position of the mouse as we would
predict based on the the activity data
from the hippocampus now we can also
test how well this representation of
space in the hippocampus may be accurate
how long is the mouse maintain this
neural representation of space kin in
some regards to a spatial memory we can
perform this test by constructing the
decoder on one day and testing its
performance when the mouse runs really
near track on a different day so here
you can see data and this top row from a
five-day interval between the
construction of the decoder and its
application to predict the mouse
is location five days subsequent here in
this middle row you can see the same
kind of test with a 15-day interval
between the construction of the decoder
and its testing and the decoder has
indeed lost some of its accuracy but is
still very accurate down here in the
bottom row we can see the results from a
thirty of a lapse between the
destruction and the testing of the
decoder the decoder indeed has again
lost some fidelity over these shorter
intervals but nevertheless is making
predictions about the mouse's location
that are highly statistically
significant in more recent experiments
we can now begin to track how the animal
and the hippocampal neural dynamics will
learn the representation of a new
spatial environment in the context of a
long-term spatial navigation and memory
test here you can see a movie on the
left in which in Mouse is navigating a
eight-armed
radial maze one of the arms has been
baited with a reward for the animal on
each trial we start the animal in one of
the other seven arms the animal has to
look at some distal spatial cues which
are not visible in this video there on
the wallpaper of the arena and based on
these cues the animal can navigate to
the goal arm and receive its reward as
the animal learns to do this over
multiple days we can track the patterns
of hippocampal neural activity and
extract the hippocampal representation
of space and begin to examine the manner
in the time course with which the
hippocampus will learn this radial maze
and related to the animals progressively
improved performance so I hope to have
illustrated for you now that by
combining a variety of different methods
we have promising new capabilities for
tracking neural ensemble dynamics and
the information that they encode over
the course of long term experiments
regarding memory a storage and recall in
the last portion of the talk I'm now
going to show you how we are creating
new optical technologies that my
colleagues and I will be you
for us for studies of memory as part of
our u19 project to summarize we are
developing optical techniques that will
allow us to image more than one brain
area at time and to see how different
brain areas can cooperate together in
the service of long-term memory we are
also working with techniques that allow
us to perform causal manipulations
Optive up to genetic manipulations at
the site of imaging in the brain I'll
show you how we are developing and using
techniques for imaging neural activity
across the dorsal mantle of the cortical
surface and finally I will discuss some
techniques that allow us to track neural
activity by using the transmembrane
potential of neurons rather than the
concentration of intracellular calcium
as a proxy for neural activity with
these newer methods we can track and
revolta dynamics directly so let's look
at these individual new emerging
technological approaches so first if we
want to be able to image the dynamics of
more than one brain area at a time one
simple approach is to implant more than
one miniature optical microscope and
here you can see a mouse that is
navigating a forearm plus maze as it
wears two different microscopes one that
is allowing us to track the somatic
calcium dynamics of neurons in the
prefrontal cortex while the other
microscope is allowing us to track
somatic calcium dynamics of hippocampal
primal cells and so in this way we can
visualize and analyze how these two
different brain areas may be courting
their activity patterns as the animal
performs this spatial navigation task
the most recent versions of the
miniature microscope incorporate two
different light sources one that permits
optical imaging of calcium activity and
another that permits optogenetic
manipulations of neurons under the same
field of view
to access the neural dynamics across the
dorsal surface of the mouse neocortex we
have developed a mouse preparation that
we call the Crystal Skull in this
approach we permanently implant in place
of the natural cranium a curved glass
window that provides long-term optical
access to the cortical surface here you
can see some examples of the use of the
Crystal Skull this is a transgenic mouse
made by monkeys and her colleagues at
the Allen Institute this animal
expresses a genetically encoded calcium
indicator in layer two three new
cortical pyramidal cells this mouse is
running and using a fluorescence
microscope we can track a somatic
calcium activity across the cortical
surface if we zoom in you can see more
clearly the activity patterns of
individual neurons each one of those for
us in spots
represents an an individual neuron
firing probably a burst of action
potentials and we can zoom in even
further this panel here on the right
shows you a magnified view of this inset
here and we can very clearly see the
activity patterns of the individual
cells as well as the hemodynamics
through the different blood vessels here
so through this crystal skull we can
perform a variety of different optical
imaging techniques some of the images
that result from both one photon imaging
two photon fluorescence imaging here are
shown in this set of images for example
here is a montage of pyramidal cells in
a coronal view comparison to the Allen
brain map shows that we can sample cells
in about 36 to 40 brain areas across an
individual animal that is wearing a
crystal skull and we are now using this
technique in collaboration with Yoruba
sakis lab to be able to track patterns
of neural activity associated with sharp
wave ripples as you can imagine as we
gather information about the dynamics of
neurons across so many different brain
regions at a time our computational
pipeline is absolutely critical and by
refining it to work quickly and on
high-performance computing clusters we
can now analyze data more quickly than
we can even acquire it so this is an
example in which we have distributed the
code across 56 different computer cores
to analyze datasets covering multiple
brain areas at a time
finally I'm going to tell you about work
developing and applying fluorescent
optical voltage indicators that allow us
to track the transmembrane potential of
neurons directly rather than the
intracellular concentrations of calcium
and the rises in calcium that are
associated with spiking now using
voltage indicators we can track action
potential dynamics and membrane
potential dynamics directly our efforts
in this regard have focused up on a
particular class of fluorescent voltage
indicators known as fret obstinate
voltage indicators that allow us to
detect individual action potentials with
high signal-to-noise ratio using only
milliwatts of light and here to
illustrate you can see an electro
physiologically recorded trace from one
neuron at the same time you're in the
blue the optical trace recorded from the
same neuron and you can see that the two
traces match very well we catch each and
every spike with the optical voltage
indicator we have verified the fidelity
of this approach in the brains of live
mice using simultaneous electrical and
optical recordings in this case we're
looking at an optical recording from a
particular voltage indicator known as h2
n/m neon green we performed concurrent
loose patch electrical recordings and
optical voltage recordings and showed
that we could catch each and every spike
in the optical traces moreover using the
electrical records as the ground truth
we found that we could time the spikes
from the optical records to within plus
or minus 200 microseconds
Speight timing precision
together with collaborators at Yale we
have been exploring new versions of the
fluorescent optical voted indicators
with different fluorescent colors we
have a red version of the indicators we
have a green version the red version is
known as Varna and was published in 2018
and we can now therefore look at the
voltage dynamics of two different cell
populations at once and one way we're
exploring this is with a fiber optic
measurement technique that we call tempo
which stands for transmembrane
electrical measurements performed
optically and I won't go into all the
details of how this approach works but
it is designed to allow us to look at
optical voltage rhythms a phenomenon
which is critical to our u-19 project on
sharp wave ripples this measurement
technique actually attains the physical
limit on sensitivity that is set by
photon shot noise and improvements
thereby will come for example with
improved indicators over time but the
instrumentation is already reaching the
physical limits on sensitivity tempo has
several advantages over conventional
electrical field recordings for sensing
the patterns of voltage oscillations in
the live brain first of all tempo allows
us to target with the genetically
encoded fluorescent voltage indicator
specific cell types of interest this is
not possible electrical field recordings
moreover the interpretations our
recordings are substantially improved in
the sense that we know we are monitoring
transmembrane voltage directly we do not
have to worry about interpretive
difficulties from volume conduction
effects as is often an issue with
electrophysiological field recordings
the specific neuron types that we target
with our voltage indicator can be sparse
such as different subclasses of
interneurons
we often have superior sensitivity to
electro field recordings in non laminar
areas of the brain and overall with
tempo there are new opportunity to die
the different contributions of selected
cell types to the voltage rhythms that
we might see with electrical field
recordings so here's an example in which
we use the red fluorescent Varnum
indicator targeted to hippocampal
pyramidal cells the traces on the top
are from a running Mouse and you can see
that the theta rhythm in the 6 to 10
Hertz range that we've recorded with the
optical approach um corresponds very
well to what you see with a local field
potential recording near the tip of the
optical fiber that's been implanted into
the hippocampus and we see the same
level of concordance here in the Delta
band when the mouse is not moving the
optical approach works very well and at
higher frequency bands for example these
are recordings of a sensory evoke
neocortical gamma oscillation and with
our colleagues we are working on on
extending this approach to this arch to
the sharp wave ripple band now one of
the important aspects of tempo is that
it offers the possibility of dissecting
different cell type contributions that
brains oscillatory phenomena and here
you see this illustrated with a delta
rhythm in one case we've targeted the
indicator to pyramidal cells shown here
in the orange trace in another case
we've targeted the indicator to
parvalbumin positive inter neurons
during the green trace and we are
referencing these oscillations seen
optically through the local field
potential seen here in the blue traces
the frequencies of oscillation in the
different traces of the star are the
same between this example in this
example but their different phase shifts
suggesting that the pyramidal cells and
the inter neurons can play different
roles in constructing the field
oscillation and so we hope to do more of
this going forward particularly in the
context of sharp wave ripples we're
going to be applied
this approach again in collaboration
with Yoruba sakis lab as part of that
effort within our u19 project so in
closing I'd like to thank all of the lab
members and collaborators that
contributed to different aspects of this
work and the different funding agencies
that made this work possible in
particular the NIH brain initiative that
is underwriting our collaborative u 19
grand project thank you for your
attention
you
hello let's now talk about some of the
inhibitory interneuron or micro circuits
that may underlie the generation and
mechanisms of sharp wave ripples and
multiscale modeling that we use to
understand them so so far the emphasis
has been on excitatory circuits within
the hippocampus to a large extent such
as the granule cells of the dentate
gyrus ce3 of the CAC period all cells
and ca1 pyramidal cells these major cell
groups of course are connected by
excitatory synapses however in a brain
region such as the ca1 this is true for
any cortical region in addition to the
excitatory glutamatergic cells there are
also a lot of other cell types that are
very diverse and they come in different
shapes and sizes and we refer to them as
GABAergic into neurons as you can see on
the on this slide here we distinguish
within the ca1 something approximately
about 20 to 30 inter neurons you see 15
of them listed here these are the most
important types but there are others as
well
and these inter neurons are classified
based on their input output
characteristics there where the soma is
located where the dendrites are and
which part of the pyramidal cells the
axons innervate the pyramidal cells
themselves are not indicated in this
figure but they would be located in the
stratum pyramidal layer that's indicated
as SP in this lay in this drawing so you
see for example that there are about
9,000 or dopamine positive in 10 Euron's
indicated in red at the bottom in the CA
one of a rodent and they consist of
various subtypes like section across
chandelier cells that innervate the
initial segment of pyramidal cells
basket cells that in early
the very somatic region and by
stratified cells that innervate the
proximal end runs there are also other
types for example neuropeptide Y
positive cells or somatostatin positive
cells or cholecystokinin positive cells
and these are all labeled here and
indicated as color and the numbers are
also indicated now in the ca1
we have about 300 thousand or more ca1
pyramidal cells so these baburaj akin to
neurons or few in numbers relatively to
the more much more abundant pyramidal
cells but they are play an incredibly
important role as you see on the right
and I'm just going to use here the
example of the part of the main and CCK
basket cells these cells these inter
neurons are not just different in terms
of their dendrites and axons their
morphology but in fact they are
different in all kinds of other ways
molecularly and their connectivity and
their product properties as well so
let's just discuss this for a minute for
example the power between cells are they
receive a lot of excitatory inputs as
you see feed-forward intimate Rajic
inputs as well as feedback butum
allergic inputs they fire very fast
action potentials in a non accommodating
manner their time constant membrane time
constant is fast so they are really made
to process signals very fast at high
fidelity and even when you look at their
X on all terminals what you see is that
when they release GABA they release the
unison with the GABA they cause
postsynaptic inhibitory events in the
pyramidal cells with high fidelity in
other words whenever there is a
presynaptic action potential we see a
temporally tightly coupled postsynaptic
response contrast this with the CCK
basket cells and those are also basket
cells they innervate the very somatic
regions but the cc-care cholecystokinin
positive cells could not be different
more different than the PV cells from
the previous cells indeed they receive
relatively few excited
in put-put America excitatory inputs and
they fire regular spikes slower spikes
that do accommodate they have slower
membrane time constants and then when
they release GABA they generally release
GABA in what we call an asynchronous
manner as indicated on the bottom little
square there so each of these internal
subtypes really are little machines that
that are connected in the circuit
differently and they express a variety
of of sodium and potassium channels and
calcium channels that are very specific
to the internal subtypes as well as
other neuromodulatory receptors
distributed across these different cell
types in a very cell type-specific
manner so how do these inter neuron all
subtypes behave during ripples that's
really the question here so I'm going to
show you some data from my lab that we
obtained using what we call JAXA cellar
recording techniques these are
techniques where we in vivo we approach
the single cell with an electrode and we
record a single cell and then we feel it
and that cell cells activity is recorded
and then we post hoc verify that indeed
that cell was for example a part of MU
in baskets eldest that you see up there
with the red dendrites and the blue
axons and then in some cases we also
show that they are part of moving
interactive and we use electron
microscopy to verify that indeed these
part of basket cells form synapses on
some on Samata at the bottom you see the
so-called OLM cells which is named after
the fact that the fact that the cell
body is in the Orient's layer and it
projects to the lacunae the molecular
layer the distal dendritic layer of the
ca1
where the temperament of a mono fibers
come in from the internal cortex so
these are the oval and cells so these
are two different in tenure ons one of
them is a peri somatically
projecting the magic inhibitory neuron
the other one is a distal dendritic Li
projecting into neural and here is how
they fire during ripples that are
simultaneously recorded with and local
field potential LFP electrode just by
eye you can tell that the poor moving
basket cells fire on most ripples or if
not all of the reports at high
frequencies whereas the olam cells fire
on let's say 50% of the of the ripples
and when they do fire they don't fire as
much and indeed this is quantified here
now we can actually dig into the the
ripples even more and we can look at how
these two cell types fire during
individual ripple wavelets if you want
and when we look at that we can see that
for example the part of boiling basket
cell as you can see in panel e indicated
by the red arrow tend to emit action
potentials preferentially during the
rising phase of the individual rippled
wavelengths where is the one M cells the
diametrical protecting column cells tend
to fight a little bit later so this is
shown here in a more easily digestible
cartoon format you see that the red
cells the following basket cells
projected a very somatic region and they
tend to fire during the rising the
initial rising phase of these ripple
oscillations whereas the green cells the
olam cells tend to fire later so this is
a temporal ordering of Terry somatic and
ran the tag inhibition coming from these
two cell tops and you can think of ways
why this would happen the ca3 input
that's indicated there is exciting for
example the PB basket cells and the
pyramidal cells and but not the oval M
cells whose dendrites are down in the
audience so therefore the orient cells
will receive excitation only once the
pyramidal cells are firing so let me
explain this delay interestingly we
notice that such a temporal ordering is
present at other frequencies as well as
you can see here so this is an example
of frequency invariant temporal ordering
very somatic in the nicotine inhibition
because for example from the during the
theta oscillations that occur when the
animal is exploring or moving these
theta oscillations can also be picked up
by these LFP electrodes and they occur
at slower frequencies about four to ten
Hertz as you can see still the problem
in basket cells fire first followed by
the OLM cells another example that I'll
show here is that even when you dig into
the part of the mean family ourselves I
mentioned that the part of mean family
cells they comprise of the extra exonic
cells that innervate the initial segment
you see that see them in panel a in blue
and there are the basket cells that we
just discussed in red and then there are
these bastard to fight cells that are
shown here in green and by I if you look
at the these recordings you can see that
the x action excels tend to fire the
earliest during the falling phase of the
oscillations followed by the power of
the basket cells followed by the by
certified cells and you can also see
that the X racing cells not only that
they fire first but they fire very
tightly temporally logged they are
strongly modulated by the theta rhythms
whereas the other cells are modulated
less so so a temp during a but these
results show for example is that during
every single theta wave there is a sweep
of inhibition coming from this problem
in family cells from the initial segment
to the soma to the dendrites at each and
every theta wave so we have we of course
collected data from many other internal
subtypes that I don't have time to show
here and what we can do with all of
these data is that we can actually
assemble this into a multi scale model a
computational model let me just talk a
little bit about this of course I should
say that that much of the data is not
just coming from my own lab or my
collaborators lab but through the entire
neuro scientific community since the
hippo
for networks and in particular the
dentate and the c1 networks are very
well studied and by other labs all over
the world so these models in these
models we have what we have in these
models is we explicitly represent these
various interneural subtypes as you can
see in panel D we have all of these
internal subtypes at the at the right
proportion each cell number is
determined and the connectivity database
was published separately as indicated
there and then we connect these cells
through realistic synapses with
realistic synaptic numbers each cell
expresses ion channels based on
experimental data as is shown on the
right upper right with ion channel
distributions among the dendrites and
the the ion channel for example sodium
and potassium and calcium channels
generate cell type-specific firing
properties that you see here on the
right color coded for example in the top
you see in greenish color you see the
fast packing basket cells and in yellow
you see the CCK basket cells that we
discussed so then we have these cells
distributed in 3d in realistic numbers
and coupled to each other and to the
pyramidal cells in realistic ways and so
the question is what happens if this
network is just we just see what this
network can do first we can look at this
network and just be couple it from the
rest of the network so we don't drive it
with CA 3 or internal or or medial
septal rhythmic inputs and the question
is what is it that this network through
the interaction of excitatory inhibitor
cells what is it that can that it can
generate what are the emergent
properties of this Network what you can
see is that when you drive the they CA
one model is large-scale actually
full-scale multi scale model
multi-scale meaning from Italy from
synapses and molecules ion channels all
the way for the to the whole network
what we see is that theta oscillations
and phase logged gamma oscillations that
appear as you can see in a and B gamma
oscillations occur around 25 to 100
Hertz and they we know that they
normally occur at certain phases of the
theta rhythm and that is actually
captured by the by these models in
addition when we drive the ca1 model
with a particular distributed Gaussian
distributed excited to relieve
representing the shortwave
depolarization of the ca1 dendrites we
can actually see ripple oscillations
appear as well and then in the model of
course we can look at how the various
interneurons fired at any of these
rhythms and we can study whether they
match our experimental observations and
indeed we can for example see ESS as is
indicated on the right that when you
compare the model prediction with the
actual experimental data and here the
each arrow is the difference between the
firing of the model interneuronal start
topic and color coded the greenish one
is for example the problem in basket
cell again and the yellow one is the C
CK basket cell etcetera so we can
compare them in the and the size of the
arrow represents the deviation of the
model prediction from the actual data
gathered from from animals and you can
see that by a large D there is a very
good agreement between the model and the
data regarding the phase specific firing
of the very center neurons during these
slow theta oscillations and then you can
also do various interesting optogenetic
in silico of the genetic manipulations
such as
shown on the left under B so for example
in control animal you see a certain
amount of theta power and then when we
inhibit in the model the power between
basket cells in a virtual of the genetic
experiment you can see that the theta
power collapses again in agreement with
experimental observations and I should
say that these modeling results are not
just interesting when there is agreement
between model and data but the outcome
where the model doesn't agree with the
data is equally interesting because then
we can dig into that and try to
understand why there is a disagreement
and we can then carry on with new
experiments so this was all about
oscillations but we can also model and
we are starting to do this more and more
spatial feature selectivity and let me
explain to you what I mean by this
so with experiments we can focus on
certain cell types and I'm going to
bring in here the so-called mossy cells
that had been great interest to me and
many others which are actually
excitatory cells in a way you could call
them into neurons since their axons
don't leave the hippocampus these are
excitatory cells located within the
dentate gyrus and they innervate granule
cell and internal dendrites and
interesting feature is that many in many
neurological disorders such as epilepsy
ischemia and others these muscle cells
are selectively vulnerable so that has
triggered a lot of interest in these
cells but what do they do in the normal
brain in 2017 three papers appeared two
from our collaborators our team members
from during the Jackie's lab and athelas
lab in neuron all showing basically that
the dentate gyrus mossy cells in
behaving mice are very sensitive in
their so called plays field activities
to small changes in the environment as
that's shown in
diagram from Duty's world and you can
see that even compared to the granule
cells where these place fields or
granule cells don't remap much in this
particular experiment whereas the
mostess cell place will are
preferentially remapping or changing and
the animal is moved between environments
these these results from these three
labs from the GU jockey law Santi and
Jim Canadians labs all pointed to a
potential role of mossy cells in spatial
coding and indeed then we tested this
idea do they actually play a role in in
spatial memory encoding with and Bui in
my lab and this is shown here so if you
taken any more where we can manipulate
muscle cells inhibit muscle activity
when we want to using optogenetics and
you put a normal animal an animal here
with without the light on without
inhibiting mossy cells what you see is
that in this particular paradigm during
training which lasts about 10 minutes
this is called the object location
memory test animals sneak those two
objects roughly equally they are curious
animals and then you can take the
animals out for a day and I'll put that
back during the testing period this is
under a panel see here for a few minutes
five minutes in this case with one
object moved and normal animals and this
is what you see here on the right in
grey bars either in the dorsal ventral
hippocampus as shown in with grey will
sniff the new object much more they are
curious it's a little bit like you go
home and you see that your favorite
chair is moved in the room you are going
to look at that more similarly with
maths so normal animals that are kind of
remembering where that object was this
is why it's a test of spatial memory
however the interesting thing comes that
when we inhibit most cells during the
training during the learning period what
we see is that the mice don't
differentiate between the moved and the
unmoved object this is show
on the on the right with those orange
bars that are basically a chance level
they are not differentiating between the
moved and the unmoved objects as if they
don't remember the spatial position of
the original spatial position of the
objects and it doesn't matter whether we
inhibit muscles in the dorsal ventral
hippocampus during training however
notice that under D when we inhibited
mossy cells during testing then there
was no effect the mice performed with
the mossy cells decoupled from the
network just as well as control marks so
this is an example of how we can dig
into specific cell types in terms of
their role in spatial memory encoding
which is of course very important for
the ripple related memory play so we can
actually dig into this even more using
modeling techniques that I talked about
so in this case we are building a
large-scale multi scale model of the
dentate gyrus with all those inter
neurons and the granule cells the
criminal cells so the granules are the
principal cells of the dentate gyrus as
well as mossy cells that you see in red
in the highlights of the dental gels the
right connectivity connectivity again
and as you see in the bottom left
each granule cell has its own unique
dendrite and these granule cells are
distributed in 3d as you see in the
middle in that 3d image and these cells
are then connected in a cell
type-specific and distance dependent
manner as is indicated on the right you
are now looking at the flattened out
dentate gyrus network and we can model
the topography of the spatial inputs to
the hippocampus from the Intrado grid
cells that we know as shown on the
bottom left that the grid cell spacing
change as a function of the
dorsal-ventral position in the internal
cortex these fibers go into the dentate
gyrus
and we represent them explicitly and
then we run the simulations using a
virtual mouse running through the field
and excite various internal grid cells
in a 2d spacial rate map as shown there
and then the question is do we get an
emergent playstyle activity in granule
cells and muscle cells and the answer is
we do and that's shown on the right and
then we can study what proportion of
granule cells for example have no place
fields what proportion had one or two
place fields and what is the information
content of this place rules and we can
compare them to any other cell type in
this case the mossy cells but we can
also do that with with in the ca1 and
and and ask similar questions elsewhere
as well all of these modeling in this
multi scale very large model networks is
a difficult enterprise and we use
supercomputers for this funded by NSF
funds such as funding mechanisms such as
the the exceed program that is a
excellent program and and and we can
also develop we do develop new modeling
tools such as the what is written here
as the multi objective network
optimization framework bye-bye
by our team by mostly led by Erin
Milstein and even Rykov and the idea
here is to really solve this big problem
of how you optimize such an at large
network with hundreds of parameters
ranging from channel densities of
variants ion channels to to synaptic
strengths and synaptic kinetics etc and
as you can see the idea here is to run
each model through a battery of
simulated experiments in parallel and
evaluate the multiple potentially
conflicting objectives and compared to
experimental targets such as input
output slope spike rate adapt tation
attenuation from dendrite
synaptic integration at others and at
each iteration choose new models based
on past model performance so we are
trying to work on these new methods to
optimize this very large frameworks
networks to actually arrive at a really
good representation of these hippocampal
networks and get of the sharp wave
memory generation and replay and the
mechanism seller synaptic mechanisms
that underlie all of these events now
it's an important problem that our labs
should be able to freely change exchange
data but exchanging data is only
possible if there is a shared
specification for neuroscience data and
there is a large effort that's an
international effort going through many
lives and we are part of that led by Ben
dictor our data scientist and this is
called the neuro data without borders
effort and you see that the idea here is
to use for example electrophysiology
data like multi unit arrays from duty
boo Jackie's lab or optical physiology
from auto laws and Marx labs and
simulation data from my lab and other
labs and really to be able to freely
exchange these data data using a common
format so there are n WB data storage
data storage rules as you see on the
right input/output tools and rule
enforcement and various analysis and
visualization tools and rules have
really helped the seamless integration
of the of this team effort through
between labs between the team labs as
well as with outside labs and this
really helps not just data sharing but
also to sharing data archiving and
reproducibility as well so I hope you
have enjoyed this webinar
from lab roots and I hope that you were
convinced they are not convinced of the
extreme value of team science that made
all of this advance possible in a such a
short period of time so a big shout out
and thanks to NIH for the brain
initiative thank you